welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and you now locked
into the channel where we break down all
the latest movies and new game releases
TV shows and comic books this episode
we're gonna be going over everything
that you need to know about the king on
Netflix as well as its twist ending and
the real-life story behind it throughout
this video we'll be discussing the
haircuts history and our general
thoughts on the film now there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch the movie yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of the
king it's the 1400s and we follow Henry
Prince of Wales also known as how
throughout the majority of the story Hal
just wants to stay away as far from the
trappings of royalty as possible distant
from his warmongering and paranoid
father Henry the fourth who spends the
majority of his life drinking Henry
calls for Hal informing him that he will
not be king even though he is the eldest
child and instead his younger brother
Thomas will be inheriting the role and
he informs Howard his sibling wishes to
fight and put an end to a rebellion it
looks like he's even more war hungry
than Henry seniors and this drives one
of the big conflicts early on there's a
lot to take on board and those who
haven't got a PhD in history may get
lost with the plot however here in
England we have to learn all of this
crap growing up and what basically boils
down to in my expert opinion is a tale
of someone who is forced to be a leader
that doesn't want to lead Thomas and how
both go to fight the Hotspur rebellion
with the former feeling upstage by the
late arrival of his brother who steals
his glory
killing Hotspur with a blade thus ending
the fight before he even really begins
it's an awesome introduction that really
elevates the movie early on and this is
a game of clones in all the right ways
with it mimicking some of the early
production styles of the series to great
effect Hal tells his brother to bail on
fighting people at dress of his Iron Man
when he escaped the cave but Thomas
ignores this and is killed shortly after
Henry the fourth succumbs to old age
about 30 which was normal back then and
as Hal is the only surviving member
his lineage he is pronounced King unlike
his father though howl doesn't want to
be paranoid and war hungry constantly
angry because his cousin didn't like his
status and instead he opts to be a
beacon of peace and prosperity this
doesn't sit too well with others though
and as an insult the King of France
sends a ball which as we all know from
our middle school history class is worse
than having someone say doth have thou
wear those mothers drapes whilst it
would emasculate most Hal sees it as a
positive confirming that he is doing the
right thing but old Frenchie won't stop
and apparently an assassin is sent by
King Charles the six of France to kill
Hal
left with no choice how decides to
announce that they are going to war with
the country and they're gonna be heading
off to France joined by William
Gascoigne his chief advisor and pal
staff they start to ride to war in the
hopes of cementing Henry is a formidable
king that deserves some respect they
arrive in the country and Laith each
sorry siege to the land which is when
the movie introduces its main
antagonists played by Robert Pattinson
he really knocks it out of the park and
provides a complete polar opposite to
the roles that the acting only tends to
play making fun of just how big house
balls are he also kills kids cuts their
heads off
looks like he's auditioning for a lorry
allied where and basically I don't know
why Hal just didn't kill him early on
Hal's forces ride through the land and
eventually come face to face with the
French army who by far I'll match them
in numbers against most of his advisers
Hal decides that it's time to strike and
he says if it rains tonight we fight
tomorrow this is because the King knows
that the extra armor and horses that a
French army carry will get stuck in the
mud which will allow their longbow men
to rain down on them before the Battle
of Hal goes to the Dauphin challenging
him to a one-on-one fight which will
decide the outcome of the battle saving
countless lives
the Dauphin refuses and he's not really
doing much for the French coward
stereotype and nurse the battle
commences I pray I'm pretty sure no no
French people watch this channel right
oh can we just check yeah we'll find how
delivers a roaring speech about England
that will make any blue blooded Brit
shed a tear and the battle begins it's a
great conflict that really feels like
the highlight of the entire film and
it's clear that Netflix
no expense with the reenactment watching
a massive soldiers march through the mud
is brilliant and it's rare to see a
battle play out like this with such
authenticity the plan works - and the
English beat the soldiers using their
surroundings to their advantage however
just as you think foul stuff is about to
deliver brexit he is killed both howl
and the Dauphin enter the battle with
the former murdering many soldiers in an
incredible one-shot fight that spans the
field and sort of fields under touch
with an ounce of sadness as we watch him
slowly turning into the man that he
promised never to be the battle ends
with the Dauphin entering the conflict
and constantly slipping in the mud which
really gives him a humiliating end the
guy looks like an absolute idiot and
it's an awesome way showed just how
laughable a bolita that he was how Lord
is the president's to be murdered and
slowly starts us to come to the dark
side Wars make warriors and there's a
real hint here that how maybe becoming a
monster which holds wait for the
eventual end of the story
following this major defeat of the
French army how travels deeper into the
country with his forces and eventually
comes face to face with King Charles the
sixth who surrenders and offers how his
daughter's hand in marriage to unite
their Kingdom mr. Steele your daughter
accepts and returns home with his new
wife now this is where the big twist
happens and we're gonna break down what
it was about and the motivations behind
it Hal's new wife Catherine believes
that Hal is a war mongering idiot much
like his father and she refuses to
submit to him stating that he must earn
her respect she asks if he feels a sense
of achievement and questions why he
invaded France which is when the big
reveal happens it turns out that the
assassin earlier on in the movie that
pretty much started the entire conflict
was not sent by King Charles and it was
all a play by William Gascoigne to
manipulate the king and get him to go to
war this is because William due to the
conflict has gained a lot of new land
which he's set to make a fortune off how
questions William on how he managed to
capture the assassin and the
silver-tongued snake quickly contradicts
himself being unable to explain where or
when or how he managed to find him this
pretty much confirms how its worst fears
and the King kills his servant after he
exclaims that he has given him what he
wanted which is peace how requests that
Catherine always tells him the truth to
avoid going to war once more and thus
the film ends showing that though it
looked like how was going to become his
father he has advisors around him that
will stop this now in real life this
didn't happen the way that the film
depicts it at all with Gascoigne
probably being removed from his post or
resigning after the appointment of King
Henry the real Gascoigne died in 1419
and was buried in Yorkshire however we
don't know all of this for certain and
there's a lot of accounts that
contradict this including Shakespeare's
Henry the fourth part to you in which
Henry the fifth is crowned and he tells
Gascoigne that he will continue to hold
this post this may have some actual
historical basis though it could also be
like this movie and doing it for
dramatic effect but it may suggest that
his resignation was voluntary as for
Henry while he died in 1422 at the age
of 35 due to dysentery again though this
is completely up for debate with some
believing that it was due to heat stroke
because he'd been riding in full armor
the day before in blistering heat and
unfortunately the medical equipment that
we have today it didn't exist back then
so we have no way of knowing Henry
reigned for nine years before his demise
and named his son Henry the sixth the
King Henry was only a few months old at
the time but he did reign for 50 years
which was pretty much like being a
hundred back then there's a lot of
history to the family that we don't
really have time to get into here but
it's definitely worth checking out
especially Henry the eighth who is
pretty much a psychopath that had six
wives some of which he executed because
blocking people on social media didn't
exist back then overall though I really
enjoyed the film and it's always great
when historical epics like this remind
us of the sort of lives that our
ancestors used to lead the film though
not perfect is still a great addition to
the Netflix platform and in 4k Dolby
vision and the movie really shines as
with most historical movies like this
the film is slightly lenient with the
truth and it changes many of the events
in order to create a more engaging
narrative that's probably the only major
downfall I can see people finding with
the king and it's really well acted and
portrays the darker side of the monarchy
and the way that they used to act being
above the law allowed to murder people
without trials based purely on judgment
the king is a brilliant character study
on a man becoming his own father even
though he tries his best not to and
whether he will or won't succumb to this
is where the main drama comes from and
overall it's an enjoyable watch that I
think many people will find fascinating
the King was great and it gets an 8 out
of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the king so make sure you
leave your review of the movie in the
comment section below if you want to
come chat to me after the video then
please follow me on twitter at
definition whitey will head over to my
discord server which will be linked in
the description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with all the
latest videos on the channel so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
the marble face repo Wambach's 7 blu-ray
which contains Civil War Doctor Strange
homecoming or Ragnarok and more and all
you have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video make sure that
you subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on the king in the comment
section below the winners gonna be
chosen the 15th and Oberman the set will
be shipped out from then to ever gets
the prize so best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is the channel for
people who were mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you